[Musik]
hallo meine lieben wie versprochen geht
es heute weiter mit dem nächsten
nudelgericht denn wir haben ja nudel
monat und ich zeige euch jeden dienstag
im februar ein neues kurzes knackiges
und leckeres nudelgericht heute kommen
die champignon fans voll auf ihre kosten
denn ich zeige euch heute leckere nudeln
mit einer champignons sahnesoße wir
benötigen passt da ich habe mich hier
für spaghetti entschieden außerdem
champignons egal ob braune oder weiße
etwas sahne zwiebeln knoblauch etwas
olivenöl mail und an gewürzen salz
pfeffer gemüsebrühe und muskatnuss die
muskatnuss könnt ihr übrigens auch
komplett weglassen oder durch
paprikapulver ersetzen
die champignons habe ich bereits geputzt
und schneide sie jetzt in dünne scheiben
[Musik]
danach werden die zwiebeln in kleine
feine stücke geschnitten und dann geht
es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
zu dem kochenden wasser gebe ich jetzt
noch reichlich salz und gäbe dann die
spaghetti hinein
in der zwischenzeit wird schon mal das
öl in der pfanne erhitzt
wie in all meinen nudel rezepten für
diesen monat gebe ich euch das
versprechen dass die soße für die nudeln
immer schneller beziehungsweise genauso
schnell fertig ist wie die nudeln und
jetzt geben wir die knoblauch in eine
knoblauchpresse erhöht sich natürlich
auch klein schneiden können und dann
wird das schon mal angedünstet
anschließend geben wir die klein
geschnittenen zwiebel mit dazu und
dünsten sie ebenfalls an die temperatur
ist bei mir hier nicht auf höchster
stufe sondern eher auf dem mittleren
sobald die nudeln glasig gedünstet sind
geben wir unsere champignons mit dazu
und die brauchen gar nicht solange etwa
ein bis eineinhalb minuten danke hansa
und dann geht es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
sobald die champignons dann weich
geworden sind geben wir das mehl mit
hinzu und verteilen das gut
das mail hilft uns dabei dass die soße
ein wenig gebundener wird und ein
bisschen fester wird und wer darauf
verzichten möchte da kann das natürlich
auch gerne tun dann ist die soße nur ein
wenig flüssiger
jetzt geben wir noch die sonne langsam
mit hinzu und verrühren das gut
miteinander
das ganze wird jetzt ein mal aufgekocht
unter ständigem rühren und dann geben
wir schon die gewürze mit hinzu
unsere champignons soße ist an der
stelle auch schon fertig und sobald
nudeln auf gar sind können wir das ganze
anrichten
ich gebe immer ganz gerne die nudeln mit
soße
damit sich das ganze richtig schön
vereint und man ganz viel soße für die
nudeln hat die können es aber natürlich
auch klassisch machen indem er erst eure
spaghetti neuen teller gibt und dann die
soeste darauf verteilt
die menge der nudeln reicht übrigens für
drei hungrige personen und ihr könnt
euch das ganze jetzt noch schön warm
schmecken lassen er schmeckt aber auch
am nächsten tag noch sehr lecker
zum schluss gebe ich da ganz gerne
getrockneten oder frischem basilikum
hinzu je nachdem was ich gerade da hat
und dann wünsche ich euch jetzt schon
mal einen guten appetit
nächsten dienstag geht es dann schon das
nächste nudelgericht dass ihr in unter
15 minuten fertig habt falls ihr keines
meiner videos mehr verpassen möchte dann
hinterlasst mir gerne ein kostenloses
abo teilt eure rezeptfotos fleißig auf
instagram mit dem hashtag kies kitchen
darüber freue ich mich sehr
und dann sage ich bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]